streamers are being so lazy it might be
illegal that's right professional live
streamer xqc is facing accusations of
stealing content for his own reaction
videos while making a complete mockery
of other people's intellectual property
rights oh hold on this part's great man
I love this guy welcome back legal
eaglets today it's time to think like a
lawyer because we're going to be
covering one of the most misunderstood
aspects of copyright law fair use so
hold on because it depends but for those
not in the know xqc is one of the most
popular and highest paid internet
personalities over the past decade the
27 year old French Canadian has
cultivated a dedicated following for his
unique style of unfiltered commentary
for video game live streams and YouTube
videos
now xqc's most recent controversy kicked
off when he uploaded a video to his
YouTube Channel showing himself reacting
to another Creator's video on the JFK
assassination
about to return to ground level given
spotted Oswald approaching but while
reaction videos typically involve lots
of pausing and constructive commentary
on selected Clips xqc's video is almost
exclusively just him watching the
entirety of another person's 90 minute
video this triggered an influx of
backlash from other YouTubers who
accused xqc of free writing off of
another Creator's hard work all while
reaping Financial rewards via clicks and
AD revenue xqc is saying next to nothing
again it's just like wow this video is
popular so I'm gonna sit in the corner
my audience will do basically whatever I
say and I'll say it next to nothing and
make free money and to make matters
worse sometimes he even keeps the video
playing while he leaves to use the
bathroom or make lunch
who allowed various work
do not pose this to YouTube for the lack
of react for the lack of react
boom and of course xqc is not the only
streamer who reacts to other people's
videos in real time with almost no
commentary it's all over the place
[Music]
now xuc claims he's done nothing wrong
and accused his critics of being envious
of his success now as a YouTuber who has
produced my own share of reaction videos
and had their videos reacted to by
others this is an issue that is near and
dear to my heart and more importantly my
wallet and the transformative nature of
fair use is one of the most
misunderstood areas of the law on the
internet so today let's take a deep dive
into one of the most heated debates on
online content creation and fair use
that's happening right now now Felix
Ling yell better known as xqc has spent
nearly a decade building a devoted
online following as a former top-ranked
competitive OverWatch player turn
streamer and content creator and on the
live streaming platform twitch and now
kick xqc regularly chats with fans host
reality shows and broadcast himself
playing video games
and on his YouTube channel as you see
makes General videos on a variety of
topics including videos of himself
reacting to other creators content and
often re-uploading his live streams now
xqc is no stranger to controversy and if
anything he rebels in it he's been
historically suspended from twitch for
various reasons ranging from a copyright
strike for live streaming the Tokyo
Olympics to an incident where he
uploaded a brief clip of two gorillas
mating which he claims was by accident
and xqc has also blurted out homophobic
sexist or otherwise bizarre comments
during live streams but ironically the
famously outspoken xuc now finds himself
Under Fire for the things he doesn't say
during his reaction videos now most
recently FTC kicked the Hornet's Nest on
July 24 2023 when he posted a video onto
his YouTube channel titled the Kennedy
assassination xqc reacts to lemino but
xqc's video is not so much a reaction
video as it is mostly just him watching
an entire 90-minute JFK documentary in
silence a number of YouTubers accused
xqc of stealing the content of a fellow
Creator while providing almost zero
commentary that would make the the video
his own first it was bub films taking
xqc to task then some ordinary gamers
joined The Fray describing the video as
garbage and this isn't the first time
that xqc's non-reactive reaction videos
have actually stirred controversy Neo a
YouTuber who creates educational videos
uh who you can also find on nebula a
criticized xqc for leaving the room five
seconds into reacting to Neo's video and
only coming back 10 minutes later which
Neo described as xqc quote making a
mockery out of the fact that he is not
reacting he also provided a graph
showing that there was no viewership
boost for Neo during and after xqc's
broadcast on the streaming side kick
which xqc recently made a 100 million
deal to join one of xqc's first streams
went South after a member of kickstaff
had to jump into the chat to stop him
from streaming the entirety of The Dark
Knight he then found himself temporarily
hidden from Kick's directory AKA Shadow
band for a second copyright violation
for Streaming breaking bad now
addressing the backlash to the Kennedy
video xuc asserted in a live stream that
he paused like crazy and added lot of
commentary to very generous statements
bro
I paused like crazy I had a lot of
commentary chat this is why I did
commentator is that streams are content
streams in their entirety or content he
then claimed he only rushed through
because his chat was quote getting mad
and after going on one of his trademark
rants he added quote yes a lot of it is
just watching it because that's what
chat wants if I commentate too much
chatty gets bored now we'll talk about
legal defenses in the future but this is
just classic the chat got bored so it's
okay to commit copyright infringement uh
I'm sure he's fine here but on Twitter
xqc hit back at some ordinary Gamer's
writing quote I'm watching a vid I like
to my people that's it whatever that
means now xqc reacted to Neo's response
uh with this incomprehensible video This
is Gonna Be uploaded
it didn't so so what's the problem so
what's the plan then people say that
it's when you upload it to the same
platform and that's the problem yeah so
what I think he's trying to say and
don't quote me on this is that he told
his editor or his social media guy not
to republish his live stream to YouTube
thinking that that's somehow
absolved him of copyright infringement
that's not the case now what this
gibbering bowther fails to understand is
that it's copyright infringement whether
it takes place during a live stream or
during a video on demand or a re-upload
it doesn't matter whether it's live or
not it's still copyright infringement it
just might be harder to actually find if
there's no actual recorded video of it
if it was a live stream that just went
off into the ether and actually when xqc
was called out during the live stream of
reacting to Neo's video for the lack of
commentary xqc just gets angry and and
makes some stuff up talking about uh
some nonsense react action about the the
metal of the pillars and stuff metal
pipes cements football goal at tobacco
wait a minute chat wait a minute hold up
I think this is a this is a very rare
copper alloy right there Chad but it
highlights the lack of actual commentary
you can't just describe what you're
seeing and call it commentary that's not
going to qualify and it highlights the
lack of anything of value that's being
added and the lack of uh
transformativeness of these reactions
but xqc described some ordinary gamers
take as quote unfounded criticism full
of personal attacks and ask some
ordinary gamers why this triggers him so
much now speaking as a lawyer and
YouTuber the reason this triggers uh
some people especially content creators
is that xqc seems to be basically
stealing other people's hard work under
the guise of creating a reaction video
which we'll talk about whether it's a
reaction or not but besides the legality
of it there are a wide variety of
attitudes toward reaction content in the
streaming Community itself Ethan Klein a
YouTuber and co-host of the H3 podcast
has emerged as a prominent voice on fair
use and one of the fiercest critics of
non-reactive content creators and on the
August 7th episode of the H3 podcast
Klein and xqc debated what counts as
fair use with respect to hosting content
xqc accused Klein of doing the same
thing by featuring smaller creatives
content on his platform you keep saying
that you're doing that you're doing
you're doing it you've come here you
call me a thief when you're doing it
then you haven't proven that I don't
know why you keep saying that however a
key difference is that H3 rarely plays a
video in its entirety and xqc asserted
that his live reactions give exposure to
smaller creators which set up a furious
response from Klein nice try you
literally do it to enrich yourself
you're a multi-millionaire and you steal
content from small creators and you
don't give a about their rights or
what they want you're not creating
anything big for anyone you're just
taking attention of your use for
yourself and you don't give a about
the the uh the consequences of that it's
not your decision to make that for other
people's property now the debate
devolved into finger pointing and
insults with Klein cutting off the
stream but not before xuc asserted
people would rather watch him do the
worm than watch Klein's podcast and he
then did so yeah oh okay sure
I mean that's Compton man it's a rich
it's original content at least
yes do that bro
and in the wake of all of this
controversy YouTuber meet Canyon created
a parody of xqc in a video he called the
tragedy of a reaction streamer in which
xqc is portrayed as a smog like monster
hoarding views though ironically the xqc
Golem in this video seems to be actually
more coherent than the real thing very
fun I liked it a lot make sure to leave
a like a click on the Bell and the a
thing and oh I think I'm in the
pose and then things got meta when xqc
reacted to the video by barely reacting
could I did maybe I could play
and then things got really meta when
Mead Canyon reacted to xqc's reaction by
barely reacting
though ironically meet Canyon's reaction
is probably the one that's most likely
to qualify as fair use because under
some circumstances parody can be fair
use and if I was his lawyer I'd argue
the parody only works if he reacts to
the whole thing without reacting
copyright can be really weird sometimes
of course copyright can be hard it's why
you need a good lawyer but if you want a
great lawyer my firm the eagle team can
help if you or a loved one has suffered
from cancer suffered an injury or death
in the family or were involved in the
car crash we can represent you or help
find you the right attorney who can just
click on the link in the description for
a free consultation with my team because
you don't just need a legal team you
need the eagle team so link below now
back to thieving streamers and this is a
perfect opportunity to talk about one of
my very favorite cases that actually
involves Ethan Klein now originally
Ethan Klein found Fame through his
YouTube channel h3h3 Productions which
was hosted by himself and his wife hila
now their content included sketch comedy
and reaction videos that satirize
internet culture and it was one of their
binding reaction videos that landed them
in federal court because in February of
2016 Ethan and Gila posted a video
mercilessly mocking the video of another
fellow YouTuber Matt hosensaida in which
his character the big bold guy attempts
to seduce a love interest using the
power of Parkour strong shoulders
he wrote that in by the way
um I don't recommend that you watch this
video it is the most cringe-worthy thing
you have ever seen in your entire life
and for some reason it still exists on
YouTube but the client's 14 minute
reaction video included numerous clips
of the big bold guys supremely cringe
video interspersed with their own
commentary and jokes and frankly they
played almost the entire video itself
while they were commentating on it I
feel so objectified
you can have me holy of course and it's
just that easy baby and in response
hodin's idea known online as Matt Haas
sued the pair in federal court for
copyright infringement and dmca
violations and in the original complaint
us accused the clients of reproducing
virtually all of the work as quote
nothing more than a prop in their comedy
routine and after the clients posted a
video discussing lawsuit Haas added a
defamation claim as well but judge
Catherine Forrest of the southern
district of New York rejected all of
haas's claims ruling that the client's
video constituted quintessential
criticism and comment that clearly fell
within the bounds of fair use in her
analysis judge Force highlighted that
the heart of the fair use inquiry is the
extent to which the purpose and
character of the use is transformative
by adding something new with further
purpose or different character noting
that commentary and criticism have a
strong presumption in favor of fair use
she cites various jokes and comments the
clients made about the video like
calling Haas the king of cringe tube
criticizing what they found to be
unrealistic dialogue between Haas and
the parkour actress and mocking the
plaintiff's parkour ability and judge
Force also analyzes uh to what extent
the client's video usurp the demand for
haas's work by serving as a market
substitute and citing the Supreme
Court's ruling in Campbell vs Acuff Rose
aka the two Live Crew case judge Force
noted that lethal parody May indeed hurt
demand for the original work and the
injury may even be intentional but that
does not produce a harm cognizable under
the Copyright Act and accordingly judge
Force found a decline's video replete
with criticism and mockery is quote
decidedly not a market substitute for
the Haas video holding that the client's
video constituted fair use judge Force
then dismissed the claims of copyright
infringement and the dmca violation and
she also tossed the defamation action
deeming the offending statements
non-actionable opinions and Ethan Klein
rightfully declared this ruling a huge
victory for fair use on YouTube but in a
footnote judge Forrest also cautioned
quote the court is not ruling here that
all reaction videos constitute fair use
she then provided helpful guidance for
why the client's video was fair use but
other reaction videos might not be quote
some reaction videos like the Klein fan
video intersperse short segments of
another's work with criticism and
commentary while others are more akin to
a group viewing session without
commentary now even though this case is
70 years old now it's a great rundown of
the fair use factors especially in the
context of an actual YouTube case which
is why I cite this case in every single
one of my video descriptions and if
lemono or Neo or others decide to sue
xqc for copyright infringement I can
pretty much guarantee that they'll quote
from this decision to argue that xqc's
videos are a group viewing session
without commentary not entitled to any
fair use defense so let's run through
this analysis for what xqc is doing and
figure out whether he has a fair use
defense or whether it's copyright
infringement now fair use is a legal
doctrine that allows unlicensed use of
copyrighted material in certain
circumstances as an affirmative defense
to infringement fair use seeks to
balance the property interests of
copyright holders with the public
interest of encouraging freedom of
expression and The Wider distribution of
creative works and while fair use is
decided on a case-by-case basis there
are certain enumerated activities that
are laid out in the copyright act as
potentially qualifying for fair use and
that includes criticism commentary news
reporting and research and that is not
an exhaustive list and in determining
whether a particular use of a
copyrighted work constitutes fair use
courts will consider the following four
factors as codified in section 107 of
the Copyright Act and no factor is
determinative you have to weigh every
single one of them the first factor is
the purpose and character of the use
including whether the use is of a
commercial nature or for a non-profit
educational purpose the second is the
nature of the copyrighted work the
amount and substantiality of the portion
used in relation to the copyrighted work
as a whole and the effect of the use
upon the potential market for or value
of the copyrighted work so for the first
Factor courts examine how the party
claiming fair use is using the
copyrighted work and while
non-commercial and educational uses are
more likely to be deemed Fair making
money from the use of another's work
doesn't automatically preclude a fair
use finding instead the key inquiry is
to the extent the use is considered
transformative and and the example that
I often use is that Jurassic Park was
originally a novel written by Michael
Crichton then eventually it was turned
into a movie Jurassic Park created by
Steven Spielberg now the movie is a
derivative of the novel and while it was
transformative to turn the novel into a
movie you better believe that Steven
Spielberg got permission and was able to
license the IP to turn the novel into a
movie if Steven Spielberg had not gotten
permission that would have been
copyright infringement and that's why
fair use can be tricky because for it to
qualify as fair use it has to be
transformative it has to create
something new but it also has to be for
the purpose and character of one of the
fair use categories that the law
recognizes as available to use for fair
use whether it's education or whether
it's commentary criticism or parody the
purpose has to be there as well as it
being transformed being transformative
alone is not enough and in fact that can
make it copyright infringement now
whether something is transformative is a
pretty complicated subject I could make
an entire video just on whether
something is transformative but here's
what the Supreme Court said in the two
Live Crew case uh quote the Central
purpose of the purpose and character of
use inquiry is to see whether the new
work merely supersedes the objects of
the original creation or instead add
something new with a further purpose or
different character altering the First
with new expression meaning or message
and in that case the Supreme Court held
that the rap group two live crew's
commercial parody of Roy orbison's song
oh pretty woman was non-infringing fair
use
the court also found that the more
transformative of the new work the less
significant the other three factors are
and as a result the first prong has
historically been the most decisive in
fair use determinations and generally
speaking you're supposed to take the
minimum amount necessary to create the
transformative work that you're creating
now parity is a little bit different
there in an exception you sort of need
to take at least enough for people to
get the joke you have to be able to
conjure up the thoughts of the original
for the parody to work but generally
speaking for fair use you're supposed to
take the absolute minimum necessary now
there's a little bit of gray area in
terms of what is minimum and what's not
but still generally speaking you're not
going to be able to take the entirety of
a work and simply play it in the
background and this is the heart of the
criticism against xqc namely that his
reaction videos are insufficiently
transformative to constitute fair use
now the second factor is the nature of
the copyrighted work which analyzes the
degree to which the work that it was
used relates to the copyright purpose of
encouraging creative expression in short
the use of copyrighted material from a
work of fiction weighs in favor of
finding infringement while taking from a
factual work likely a news item is more
likely to be deemed fair use but frankly
the courts don't put very much import
for this particular Factor unless the
work has never been published before but
the third prong considers the quantity
and quality of the copyrighted work that
was used in relation to the copyrighted
work as a whole so in other words fair
use is less likely to be found when
large portions of a copyrighted work are
used or if you're taking the heart of
the copyrighted work itself so in other
words fair use is much less likely to be
found when large portions of a
copyrighted work are used and you're
much more likely to be able to mount a
fair use defense when you only use small
portions but in some contexts even
taking a small amount of a copyrighted
material can render a use unfair if the
selection constitutes a substantial part
of the work or the heart of the work
itself so for example in a case called
Harper and Roe versus Nation Enterprises
the Supreme Court held that a news
article's quotation of fewer than 400
words from President Gerald Ford's 200
000 word Memoir constituted the heart of
the work and the use was ultimately
found to be infringing and the reason
there is because the magazine published
the part of Ford's Memoir that related
to pardoning Richard Nixon which
apparently was the only reason you would
ever read Gerald Ford's Memoir so this
would be another strike against xqc
because xqc and these other live
streamers are just republishing the
entirety of the other YouTube videos and
then reacting to it now as we saw in the
client case just because you republish
virtually all of a video doesn't
necessarily mean that you can't mount a
fair use defense but it makes it really
really hard and the more that you cite
the more you're going to have to add
commentary or some new transformative
meaning to your secondary video and then
the fourth and final Factor focuses on
whether and to what extent the
unlicensed use saps the demand for the
protected work by serving as a market
substitute in other words in assessing
this Factor courts consider whether the
use is hurting the current market for
the original work for example by
displacing sales of the original or
preventing people from watching the
original video and or whether the use
could cause substantial harm if it were
to become widespread and I think this is
yet another strike against xqc because
when you republish virtually the entire
portion of another person's video and
then you're not commenting on it with
new meeting and commentary uh why would
anyone then watch the original video
they've already seen the video on your
live stream now as someone who has made
dozens of reaction videos for this
Channel and as a lawyer who has a vested
interest in not getting sued for
copyright infringement I have a lot of
experience on how these reaction videos
are supposed to work or at least that's
how gameran feels about my channel
um but to give another example when I
reacted to the movie my cousin Vinnie I
didn't post the entire movie and I
didn't just show myself of watching it
however fun that might have been instead
I took clips and punctuated them with my
actual legal commentary you see the
traditional way of making reaction
videos is to actually react to the
videos
hey I just said that now creators who
stream for long periods of time assert
that of course there will be dead air
while they eat or go to the bathroom but
the problem with that argument is that
by the nature of live streaming you
can't take the minimal amount necessary
as required under the fair use factor
and instead you're playing the whole
thing in real time and you're not making
any discretionary Choice as to what is
actually republished and yeah biology
might dictate that you might need to
take a bathroom break but that's not a
defense to copyright infringement that's
a live streamer problem not a content
creator problem
so yes leaving to take a break will
almost certainly violate copyright due
to the lack of commentary but arguably
so does just watching it in real time if
there's no commentary being made and
this highlights why it might actually be
impossible for any live streamer to have
a live stream reaction where they're
just simply playing the entire video and
reacting because there's been no
forethought about what's the minimum
nest necessary to make the point of the
commentary or the point of the criticism
they're just playing the entire thing
and interjecting some little bits of
commentary or criticism
and courts don't look fondly when you
use the entirety of the work so yes you
could add some original commentary to
your reaction but if it completely
displaces the market for the original
it's probably not fair use and it's
pretty obvious that once you see a video
during a live stream the way that most
of these live streamers do it you're not
going to go back and watch the whole
video again let's be honest this kind of
reaction content is extremely low effort
and easy to do why because you're just
piggybacking on the work of the original
person and whether xuc is in the room or
not there's an argument to be made that
his borderline incoherent babbling might
not even qualify as the commentary or
criticism necessary for fair use anyway
honestly I think my dog could offer
about the same level of incisive
commentary as xqc during most of his
live streams yeah if you want to feel
bad just remember that apparently this
garbage is apparently worth 100 million
in dollars to the streaming platform
kick but there are some live streamers
who do things the right way if you get
permission or you get a license from the
person who owns the rights to the videos
then by all means it's great that you
are getting that permission and then
reacting to it and if you want an
example of people who do reaction
content right that aren't lawyers on
YouTube there's the popular YouTuber
Ludwig not only has he created his own
video differentiating between a genuine
reaction video and stolen content he's
also held in high regard among other
content creators for his ethical
streaming practices in particular he
asks for permission and when he reacts
to a fantastic series like jet lag also
available on nebula he continually
suggests that people sign up for nebula
so they can watch jet lag where it was
originally published so Ludwig is
evidence that it's not impossible and
another example of someone who does
reaction content the right way is Dr
Mike he is only looking at little
Snippets and then he is talking about
how that snippet relates to his chosen
practice obviously medicine now you
don't have to be a lawyer or a doctor to
do reaction content you do need to make
commentary about the thing you are
reviewing and you generally speaking
can't use the entirety of the work you
should have some forethought about what
you're going to use and what's not
necessary and ultimately
non-transformative re-uploading of
videos hurts content creators free rides
off of their hard work and likely
infringes on their IP rights if these
videos are re-uploaded in their entirety
it should be left up to the original
content creator to approve or reject it
and remember there's a super easy way to
get around this just ask permission from
the original content creator though in
defense of live streaming reaction
videos Hassan Abby said quote 90 of
creators don't mind they like it when
we're watching their videos I'm a
content creator and I love it when
people react to my videos but the thing
is that even if ninety percent of those
people would agree to it if you ask them
you still have to ask them or it's
copyright infringement and that of
course leaves out at least 10 it's
probably more than 10 percent of content
creators do actually mind and you are
explicitly going against their wishes so
ultimately the easiest way around this
that's good for everyone is just ask for
permission but streamers need to realize
that not only is it legally required to
ask for permission in many if not most
of these circumstances as well as it
being the morally right thing to do it's
also in their pecuniary interest someday
a lawyer is going to explain the concept
of statutory damages to them and they're
not going to be happy about that until
then you can support creators directly
by getting a membership to today's
sponsor nebula Neo and I are not only on
nebula but we're both co-owners because
nebula is a streaming platform built for
and by creators and this month only
they're doing something wild just until
the end of the month nebula is offering
a lifetime membership instead of a
subscription it's a one-time payment
that will get you everything nebula
offers forever I've seen a lot of
speculation about this no nebula is not
going bankrupt Linus on the contrary
it's more successful than it's ever been
but we're offering lifetime memberships
for a select few fans so that we can
make even more original content huge
Productions from your favorite creators
and we're in it for the long haul
lifetime memberships allow us to not
take on outside investors it's the
opposite of a going out of business sale
it's a going into much bigger business
sale and if you're new here nebula
offers tons of exclusive videos from me
original series from your favorite
people movies plays classes and more
including the hit series jet lag that
Ludwig was actually raving about and
with your favorites like Neo jet lag
real engineering real life lore and
legal eagle we create the content that
other people actually react to you can
see my feature length documentary bad
law words good and my other nebula
exclusive content includes my
full-length interview with the
screenwriter of my cousin Vinnie and my
not safe for work video about lawsuits
that are too hot for YouTube but like I
said for this month only you can get
exclusive lifetime membership it's 300
for life no tricks no gimmicks that's it
forever and if that's not your speed
that's completely fine you can still get
a 40 discount on yearly subscriptions
that pencils out to less than three
dollars per month if you want to pay
month hopefully you have that option too
so click on the link that's on screen
now or down below to get your lifetime
membership or a huge 40 discount I just
click right now down below before that
deal goes away then after that click on
this link over here for more legal eagle
or I'll see you in court